on the bound for the diamondbacks candy
zach gallon coming off that ucl spray in
his second start since he came off the
injured lid i think he's ready to go and
i think we're going to see more of the
exact gallon that we're used to ready to
go gallon versus colton wong is wrong
with a drive in a deep right field and
it's gone
number six on the year for colton one
and just like that the brewers are on
the board
he's something else starting games
three games back from the injured list
and he's been able to reach base
leading off the game in all three this
time a big fly
zach gallons only allowed the three home
runs including this one tonight so far
talk about getting all the one good
extension by wong on the fastball right
away one nothing brewers and here's dan
vogelback
[Applause]
call strike three jeremy riggs our
planet empire rings up vogelback and
names out number one boy nice pitch well
located fastball just off the plate and
a nice job by varsho who kind of moves
out over the plate right there glove
right there sticks it and he gets the
call oh nice bounce back for gallon one
down now ahead of christian yelling
fastball at the days he caught vogelback
looking then he rings up yelich two down
what a beautiful pitch that was too i
mean inside fastball down
and there's just yellows just can't pull
the trigger
probably thought it was a little bit low
but it was you know right in that little
gray area where it could have been
called either way and that time gallon
got the call well one more test here in
the first inning it's the big power
source for the brewers this year
avisaela garcia garcia hits one into
right david smith is there now moves a
little bit to his left makes the catch
retired garcia into the first inning a
couple of strikeouts for gallon yeah big
strikeout totals for freddie 104 punch
out 75 innings the good earned run
average of 228.
to tell martay the center fielder he's
been red hot up there lately
and sends this one slicing away from
jackie bradley jr
headed one hops the wall could tell
martay
i mean how good is this guy right now
he's killing him he's now hit safely in
seven straight and he needs a trainer
something's gone wrong with cattell
right away he signaled for the trainer
before he'd even made it to second base
here he is
walks right away something went wrong
right there right before he got to first
base he pulled up on that remember that
was the hamstring injury in the second
series of the season at colorado he
missed 37 games
and it looks like that is flared up
again yeah that's the left hamstring
once again so it's a double for marte
josh reddick comes off the bench and he
will run and take over in the outfield
presumably bottom of the second ending
car show here at the big club heading
156 to home runs two runs batted in
but he shuts him down after that there's
a little freddy fastball taste right
here for round number two
hitting 152 against the heater of
peralta payoff pitch coming an enter
right down the middle strike three
called and the inning is over two more
strikeouts for freddie peralta
one-nothing brewers josh van meter will
lead off the bottom of the fourth for
the d-max
there's another strikeout in
oh fastball freddie kind of coming back
here we've talked about the entire
arsenal but
number one is working pretty well for
him here tonight and as long as he gets
it up in the zone like that up near the
belt another swing and miss six
punch-outs now for freddie here's david
peralta swinging a mess he got him with
a slider down in the zone and it's
back-to-back strikeouts for freddie
peralta he has struck out seven now in
this outing sent gala back to work fifth
inning one nothing brewers there's a
strike got him looking that's four
caught
looking third strikes in the ball game
for a gallon of the seven strikeouts
he's got you know this is about as good
a command i think as he's had all season
he hasn't walked anybody to this point
he went to the curve ball
and bar show completes the strikeout
that's number eight for zach allen so
here's joe mantiply on for zach gallon
and supply the left-hander 16
appearances this year he last worked
sunday against the dodgers
on the ground and through into center
field a base hit
big man rounding third or
and in or no he's not he came up limping
and he's trying to hobble to the plate
and he's gonna get there as everybody
froze
for the diamondbacks vogelback came up
hobbling around third
he just stopped halfway between third
and home plate boy he's in a lot of pain
if it was a foregone conclusion that
vogelbeck was going to be able to score
on that but watch what happens i mean he
comes up lame and then is able to hobble
his way to home plate you can see
crichton screaming and yelling to get
that ball in
yet another injury for the brewers i
mean check it out i mean he just kind of
he just stops
cold between
third base and home but he's able to
hobble in
and score run number two for the brewers
and two out single by narvaez
and three on for ureas who's been really
good with the bases loaded this year for
the crew
one one pitch
swing a line drive right center field it
is down a base hit lands in front of
reddick one run is in here comes a
second run to score it's four nothing
line drive off the bat of luis urias and
it fell right at the feet of josh
reddick
that didn't clear his feet by very much
it looked like he might have been able
to make a play on it maybe he lost it in
the lights
but that's a play that could have been
made and frankly should have been made
for the diamondbacks the brewers will
certainly take it as three runs have
scored in the inning it's a two-run
single for luis urias freddie working
six innings of one hit shutout ball four
walks ten strikeouts another day at the
office another appearance one hit no
runs yeah amazing work and never to be
taken for granted
yelled singled in the fourth he's one
for three today
ellis with a drive hit back in a deep
right field and it is gone into the pool
christian yelling with home run number
four on the year and it's a five-nothing
lead for the brewers
that was a a howitzer out of here that
time
a no doubter by yelich
there's a change up
right down the middle a little bit above
the knees
providing all the power on that home run
and in the pool out in right center
look at that extension how about that
perfect balance
how far will it go
splash hunter strickland looking to
finish this one off here tonight for the
crew dalton varsio
fly ball center field jackie bradley jr
on the warning track makes the catch the
ball game is over
five nothing the brewers complete the
shutout on just two hits